some years ago I was on an airplane with
my son who was just five years old at
the time my son was so excited about
being on this airplane with mommy he's
looking all around and he's checking
things out and he's checking people out
and he sees this man and he says hey
that guy looks like daddy and I look at
the man and he didn't look anything at
all like my husband nothing at all and
so then I started looking around on the
plane and I noticed this man was the
only black guy on the plane and I
thought all right I'm gonna have to have
a little talk with my son about how not
all black people look alike my son he he
lifts his head up and he says to me I
hope he doesn't ride the plane and I
said what what did you say he says well
I hope that man doesn't rob the plane
and I said well why would you say that
you know daddy wouldn't rob a plane and
he says yeah yeah yeah what I know and I
said well why would you say that and he
looked at me with this really sad face
and he says I don't know why I said that
I don't know why I was thinking that we
are living with such severe racial
stratification that even a five-year-old
can tell us what's supposed to happen
next even with no evildoer even with no
explicit hatred this association between
blackness and crime made its way into
the mind of my five-year-old it makes
its way into
all of our children into all of us our
minds are shaped by the racial
disparities we see out in the world and
the narratives that help us to make
sense of the disparities we see those
people are criminal those people are
violent those people are to be feared
when my research team brought people
into our lab and expose them to faces we
found that exposure to black faces led
them to see blurry images of guns with
greater clarity and speed bias can not
only control what we see but where we
look we found that prompting people to
think of violent crime can lead them to
direct their eyes onto a black face and
away from a white face prompting police
officers to think of capturing and
shooting and arresting leads their eyes
to settle on black faces to bias can
infect every aspect of our criminal
justice system in a large data set of
death eligible defendants we found that
looking more black more than double
their chances of receiving a death
sentence at least when their victims
were white this effect is significant
even though we control for the severity
of the crime and the defendants
attractiveness and no matter what we
controlled for we found that black
people were punished in proportion to
the blackness of their physical features
the more black the more death worthy
bias can also influence how teachers
discipline students my colleagues and I
have found that teachers express a
desire to discipline a black middle
school student more harshly than a white
student for the same repeated
infractions in a recent study we're
finding that teachers treat black
students as a group but white students
as individuals if for example one black
student Misbah
caves and then a different black student
misbehaves a few days later the teacher
responds to that second black student as
if he had misbehaved twice it's as
though the sins of one child get piled
on to the other we create categories to
make sense of the world to assert some
control and coherence to the stimuli
that we're constantly being bombarded
with categorization and the bias that it
seeds allow our brains to make judgments
more quickly and efficiently and we do
this by instinctively relying on
patterns that seem predictable yet just
as the categories we create allow us to
make quick decisions they also reinforce
bias so the very things that help us to
see the world also can blind us to it
they render our choices effortless
friction-free yet they exact a heavy
toll so what can we do we are all
vulnerable to bias but we don't act on
bias all the time there are certain
conditions that can bring bias alive and
other conditions that can muffle it let
me give you an example many people are
familiar with the tech company next door
so their whole purpose is to create
stronger healthier safer neighborhoods
and so they offer this online space
where neighbors can gather and share
information yet next door soon found
that they had a problem with racial
profiling in the typical case people
would look outside their window and see
a black man in there otherwise white
neighborhood and make the snap judgment
that he was up to no good
even when there was no evidence of
criminal wrongdoing in many ways how we
behave online is a reflection of how we
behave in
world but what we don't want to do is to
create an easy-to-use system that can
amplify bias and deepen racial
disparities rather than dismantling them
so the co-founder of next door reached
out to me and two others to try to
figure out what to do and they realized
that to curb racial profiling on the
platform they were gonna have to add
friction that is they were going to have
to slow people down so next door had a
choice to make and against every impulse
they decided to add friction and they
did this by adding a simple checklist
there were three items on it first they
asked users to pause and think what was
this person doing that made him
suspicious the category black man is not
grounds for suspicion second they asked
users to describe the person's physical
features not simply their race and
gender third they realized that a lot of
people didn't seem to know what racial
profiling was nor that they were
engaging in it so next-door provided
them with a definition and told them
that it was strictly prohibited most of
you have seen those signs in airports
and metro stations if you see something
say something
next-door tried modifying this if you
see something suspicious say something
specific and using this strategy by
simply slowing people down next door was
able to curb racial profiling by 75% now
people often will say to me you can't
add friction you know in every situation
in every context and especially for
people who make split-second decisions
all the time but it turns out we can add
friction to more situations than we
think working with the Oakland Police
Department in California I in a number
of my colleagues were able to help the
department to reduce the number of stops
they made of people who were not
committing any serious crimes and we did
this by pushing officers to ask
themselves a question before each and
every stop they made is this stop
intelligence-led yes or no in other
words do I have prior information to tie
this particular person to a specific
crime by adding that question to the
form officers complete during a stop
they slow down they pause they think why
am i considering pulling this person
over in 2017 before we added that
intelligence-led question to the form
officers made about 32,000 stops across
the city in that next year with the
addition of this question that fell to
19,000 stops african-american stops
alone fell by 43% and stopping fewer
black people did not make the city any
more dangerous in fact the crime rate
continued to fall and the city became
safer for everybody so one solution can
come from reducing the number of
unnecessary stops another can come from
improving the quality of the stops
officers do make and technology can help
us here
we all know about George Floyd's death
because those who try to come to his aid
help cell phone cameras to record that
horrific fatal encounter with the police
but we have all sorts of technology that
were not putting to good use police
departments across the country are now
required to wear body worn cameras so we
have recordings of not only the most
extreme and horrific encounters but of
everyday interactions with an
interdisciplinary team at Stanford we've
begun to use machine learning techniques
to analyze large numbers of encounters
this is to better understand what
happens in routine traffic stops what we
found was that even when police officers
are behaving professionally they speak
to black drivers less respectfully than
white drivers in fact from the words
officers use alone we could predict
whether they were talking to a black
driver or a white driver the problem is
that the vast majority of the footage
from these cameras it's not used by
police departments to understand what's
going on on the street or to train
officers and that's a shame
how does a routine stop turn into a
deadly encounter how did this happen in
George Floyd's case how did it happen in
others when my eldest son was 16 years
old he discovered that when white people
look at him they feel fear elevators are
the worst he said when those doors close
people are trapped in this tiny space
with someone they have been taught to
associate with danger
my son senses their discomfort and he
smiles to put them at ease to calm their
fears when he speaks their bodies relax
they breathe easier they take pleasure
in his cadence his diction his word
choice he sounds like one of them I used
to think that my son was a natural
extrovert like his father
but I realized at that moment in that
conversation that his smile was not a
sign that he wanted to connect with
would be strangers it was a talisman he
used to protect himself a survival skill
he had honed over thousands of elevator
rides he was learning to accommodate the
tension that his skin color generated
and that put his own life at risk we
know that the brain is wired for bias
and one way to interrupt that bias is to
pause and to reflect on the evidence of
our assumptions so we need to ask
ourselves what assumptions do we bring
when we step onto an elevator or an
airplane how do we make ourselves aware
of our own unconscious bias who do those
assumptions keep safe who do they put at
risk until we ask these questions and
insist that our schools and our courts
and our Police Department at every
institution do the same we will continue
to allow bias to blind us and if we do
none of us are truly safe
[Music]